[Applause]
is the former u.s secretary of energy my
old job and ceo of energy futures
initiative ernest moniz is right here
doctor
how are you sir great to see you again
all right
well i wanted you here because you know
all things nuclear uh and i've been
hearing that word a lot more than i've
heard in i don't know maybe ever i mean
i was too young to remember the cuban
missile crisis but i feel like that's
the last time
we all in america had this much anxiety
about nuclear war we keep hearing about
this so i thought you're the perfect guy
to talk about this maybe you'll
allay our fears or maybe we'll all shut
our pants and jump out the window
but your head
you're ahead of something called the
nuclear threat initiative what is that
are they helping
this is about the worries we have now
right well first first of all we don't
promote nuclear threats we
try to remove them oh i understand and
uh the uh but you're absolutely right uh
there's no doubt that a lot of people i
just saw an article gen x
uh is reliving the childhood uh
concerns uh about nuclear war this has
all come about
because of putin's rather reckless
language uh in terms of uh possibly
using nuclear weapons
uh it's it's the most dangerous period
and what is your organization doing
about it that's what we're worried about
well so we have been working uh for
example we had a success in january uh
that was rapidly overturned uh we had a
success when putin along with biden and
the leaders of china the uk and france
signed a joint statement first time
that nuclear war cannot be won and
should not be fought well two months
later
putin says hey if things aren't going
well you know maybe i'm going to use a
nuclear weapon they they have a
doctrine
called escalate to de-escalate
and uh what it means is that if things
aren't going well they might use what
they call a small nuclear weapon five
kilotons
oklahoma city was two tons for example
to give you a scale it was not nuclear
and it was not nuclear and no and no
radioactivity uh right well
yeah so this is not well and at the
blast as well i mean depends where where
it lands well yes you wouldn't want to
be in the blast but the vast majority of
the world would not be in the blast but
we would
worry about
radioactive suffer from those all around
the world exactly uh and so uh the idea
is that they might use one if things are
going badly i might note things are
going badly uh
and the idea is that it would the enemy
would back off but the reality is
we think that there's as at least as
good a probability that it would
escalate to a full-fledged nuclear war
i'd say what i worry about even before
this is is the uh you know there are
lost nuclear weapons we don't know where
they all are there was a movie i
remember it i think it was with john
travolta called broken arrow mm-hmm you
ever see that movie correct right the
line that i remember that was so
chilling was that the guy says i don't
know what's scarier the fact that there
are lost nuclear weapons or that there
are so many
we have a term for it
that's what a broken arrow is this since
1950 i think there's like 32. six of
them we've never recovered one fell off
a aircraft carrier into the bottom of
the ocean it's there now
somebody has the ones we haven't found
well hopefully it's still sitting at the
bottom of the ocean well that one might
be that one but others unfortunately
american weapons fell in north carolina
for example
how do you lose a nuke
really
that's a hard
it's big
it's considered very poor military
practice
but also but but the biggest story there
really is when the soviet union fell
apart uh there was really no inventory
of weapons but even more so of the
material the uranium and plutonium to
make weapons because they never bothered
to count uh and so so we went in we the
united states and other countries we
went in hard uh the so-called nun lugar
program uh uh in russia and ukraine and
uh and belarus and kazakhstan uh to try
to nail down
all of those materials because the last
thing we want is getting into the hands
of terrorists
right well they probably used nails
that's my issue is that you know when i
see how incompetent this russian
military is
it makes me worry it makes me almost
nostalgic for the days when we thought
we could shoot them down remember star
wars i mean it was what was the official
sdi
yes under reagan but they called it star
wars but the idea was
right uh we don't have to
block them down anywhere because if they
come over we can shoot them down now
that never happened and it never could
that that's that's a myth i mean we
could perhaps shut down you know like
israel
missile conventional missiles yeah those
those are much much shorter range i
understand but the technology exists to
intercept something no well the patriot
the patriot uh defense right but we
can't shoot but uh we could probably
shoot one down maybe right from iran or
from north korea but you know if we have
hundreds of russian missiles coming in
uh
intercontinental there is there is
frankly no chance to uh to do to to
defeat that so it's
it's all deterrence
that that would be a suicidal mission
because we would do the same uh to them
you